cryptocurrency is everywhere elon musk
loves it and tweets about it mark cuban
being the savvy investor that he is has
some bitcoins himself and more celebs
like snoop dogg lionel messi and paris
hilton have jumped on that train despite
it being so popular not everyone knows
what it is how they can get some
themselves and how mining farms work
since 2020 cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
and some altcoins have seen massive
success so it's about time we all
learned a thing or two about where these
coins are mined so today we're going to
take a look at five of the biggest
bitcoin mines in the world genesis
mining technologies one thing you'll
find about these bitcoin mining farms is
that it's all about location location
location gm technologies wanted to
optimize their production so they place
great importance on their facility's
location which is why they move their
operation from china and bosnia to
finland these plain-looking sheds in the
middle of nowhere actually house one of
the world's largest crypto mining farms
inside these 400 square meter sheds are
shelves and shelves of computers
whirring away creating a deafening
racket as they perform complicated
calculations hundreds of thousands of
fans blast cold air to keep the machines
from overheating aided by six giant
ceiling turbines that spin with the
collective force of 360 washing machines
established in 2014 this trillion dollar
facility is called enigma what you're
seeing here is the enigma facility which
is the largest ethereum mining facility
in the world and it sits far away from
scenic waterfalls and lagoons that the
nordic country is famous for there is an
abundance of underground water which is
harnessed by hydroelectric dams and
geothermal power stations to produce
cheap green electricity that facilitates
the energy-intensive process of
confirming cryptocurrency transactions
the fact temperatures rarely go over 57
degrees fahrenheit or 13.9 degrees
celsius also helps genesys has also
created a hardware monitoring software
called genesis hive if a part of your
mining system fails for any reason it's
not feasible to walk around the whole
facility examining each computer with
six cpus each to find the one faulty
wire so the genesis hive helps identify
and pinpoint the issue finland is a
pretty attractive place for bitcoin
mining thanks to low electricity costs
and low temperatures it wasn't long
after bitcoin's creation in 2009 that
cryptocurrency companies started moving
to finland in 2016 giant data centers
accounted for one percent of its gdp
with crypto mining accounting for 90 of
that those centers now use more
electricity than all of iceland's homes
combined and rack up bills of one
million dollars a month it is now one of
the trailblazing countries in
cryptocurrency with eight percent of all
bitcoins being mined right here bit
river russia bit river is the largest
data center in the former soviet union
and it opened only in 2018 it has won
clients from all over the world
including america japan and china bit
river rents a building near the bratz
aluminum plant which was the world's
largest aluminum smelter it was built in
the 1960s by the ussr and there's a
hydropower plant just over three miles
away you could say this plant turns
water into cash powering the plant with
water is already impressive but another
thing that makes bit river and by
extension broadskin ideal place for
crypto is the frigid siberian climate
with its long winters the average
temperature in the winters is only 3
degrees fahrenheit or -16 degrees
celsius which helps cool all the cpu
power needed for mining and low
temperatures are suitable for the data
center equipment in general billionaire
oleg deripaska's team came up with the
idea about five years ago the n-plus
group and united ko rusal own the brazz
hydropower and aluminum plants and they
provide up to 100 megawatts of power to
bit river per year as a way to diversify
its client base and sell excess energy
cheap and stable power is a crucial
requirement of crypto mining bit river
and n plus also provide computer racks
to crypto miners bit river has roughly
20 bitcoins come in per day making
russia one of the most powerful
countries in bitcoin mining and funnily
enough bitcoin mining is actually
illegal in russia so the way bit river
gets around that little problem is by
hiring out their equipment at the data
center and their technical services to
mine which makes the whole operation
legal the size of the mine just
underlines its hash rate of 38 peta
hashes per second making the hourly
power consumption of this farm around 4
500 kilowatts which costs them a
whopping 120 000 a month and this is
actually on the low end because brats
has relatively low electricity cost in
march of 2021 bit river became
responsible for about two percent of the
world's bitcoin mining and to keep
growing they're looking to upgrade their
electricity usage current demand exceeds
700 megawatts and is quickly approaching
one gigawatt they plan to keep building
data centers and in 2021 the facility in
bratz will go from 100 to 300 megawatts
of power another 100 megawatt data
center is already under construction in
the nearby buryatya region
bitfury amsterdam bit fury isn't only
one of the biggest mining farms it's
also the oldest located in amsterdam
this farm came up in 2011 when for 10
000 bitcoin you couldn't get more than
two pizzas since then fit fury has grown
substantially the company uses several
softwares for mining so it's impossible
to calculate its hashrate unlike the
others we've seen so far bitfury isn't
just one mine but a collection of large
facilities spread across tokyo london
moscow and dubai the biggest operations
are controlled from amsterdam's
headquarters by the founder and ceo
valeri vevolov who has a net worth of
over one billion dollars in addition to
securing the bitcoin blockchain bitfury
also designs and produces innovative
hardware that keeps cryptocurrencies and
blockchain secure including custom
semiconductor chips and mobile data
centers bitfury is also a software
provider for some of the world's most
cutting-edge applications through its
exinum private blockchain framework its
crystal blockchain advanced analytics
platform and its peach bitcoin payments
portfolio they've even diversified into
music bitfury surround the company's
music entertainment division designs
blockchain solutions to address
challenges artists and other
stakeholders face in the music industry
and they are now looking at ai bitfury's
artificial intelligence division will
operate alongside its blockchain
services and build on several years of
research and development by the
company's engineering team to build
integrated product solutions at the edge
as well as cloud to edge enterprise
solutions for corporations and
governments and speaking of solutions
for corporations and governments bitfury
was one of the many companies that
donated some of its cpu-based computing
power for coronavirus research linthal
switzerland did you know that you can
get bitcoin at every teller machine at
the swiss national railway not just that
you can also use bitcoin here to buy
cars wine college tuition and basically
anything else you can think of so it
makes sense that one of the world's
largest mining farms would also be
located here the land of luxurious waste
chocolate exquisite handmade timepieces
lush mountains and bitcoin mines unlike
the farm in moscow the swiss farm's
owner is well known and open about how
his rig operates guido rodolfi built
this linthal-based farm in 2016 after
moving his setup from zurich where he
realized costs were too high to run
there so he chose a small european
village to conduct his business the farm
is in what was once a factory and it's
one of europe's largest farms still
rodolfi keeps the capacity and revenue
of his farm a secret he still needs to
solve the problem of cooling processors
but he is optimistic that it's worth
mining the bitcoin even if there are
mining issues bitmain china is it any
surprise that the world's largest mining
operation would be based in china bit
main is a chinese farm headquartered in
beijing and in 2018 it became the
world's largest designer of
application-specific integrated circuit
chips for bitcoin mining that same year
they turned a profit of
742.7 million with 11 operating farms in
china but they certainly aren't limited
to that location they also operate the
largest crypto mining pools worldwide
with antpool.com and btc.com those pools
together account for somewhere between
42 and 51
of bitcoin's total mining capacity they
also support a wide range of blockchain
platforms and startups they are even
expanding to rockdale texas where they
are constructing a 33 000 acre 150
million dollar farm which will have a
power of 25 megawatts which will grow to
300 later with over 25 000 employees in
offices in america canada russia
switzerland singapore and more they
remain the largest bitcoin mining
facility globally we've got a video all
about there on our channel so be sure to
check that out in the link below what do
you think of these mines do you believe
locations like finland might pull ahead
of the game thanks to their use of
renewable energy from mining let us know
your thoughts below if you enjoyed the
video be sure to subscribe and hit the
bell icon so you never miss a video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one